to tell me right now which one of those
monsters they will be moving in to their
own homes the only monst is you you
bastard
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana
tala brothers and sister and dear
friends I came across this disturbing
very very disturbing video of GB news
and GB news as you guys can see brother
sisters the freedom of ADV freedom of
speech Advocates who try to stop people
from coming to speak here um who make up
lies
who are pro-israeli even though they see
the absolute genocide and we're going to
have a look and see for oursel how these
people have
dehumanized Palestinians this anchor I
hope I come across him face to face one
day I would love to intellectually
destroy this dirt bag this little filthy
dirt bag that's what he is watch this
and look how he dehumanizes the
Palestinians and then you don't wonder
you no one should Wonder or be surprised
where they are Pro genocide because they
don't see them as human beings may Allah
break their backs look at this watch
this guys say it I think the majority of
people in Gaza support Hamas I think the
majority of Palestinians support Hamas I
think they support the slaughter of Jews
I think what you just saw there was the
next generation of islamist terrorists
and those labor EMP that immigration
judge just look at this picture here
okay again just look at those pictures
that imagery are these poor desperate
Palestinians they look like Hamas
supporters to me don't they and I want
the labor MPS and immigration judge Hugo
Benedict Norton Taylor to tell me right
now which one of those monsters they
will be moving in to their own homes the
only monster is you you bastard you scum
of this
Earth brothers and sisters report this
dirt bag to ofcom make sure you guys
report him to ofcom inah this absolute
of a weasel intellectually B bankrupt
scum that's what he is he a scum to look
at the camera and see innocent children
innocent woman who have been
Massac and to call them a
monster you my friend are the most evst
creatures on this Earth You have to be
an evil person to be looking at those
people and after the suffering they've
gone and that's why brothers and sisters
Hellfire is specifically made for people
like them for people like him Pro
genocidal can you imagine if Israel was
to do 1% of what it does to the
Palestinians to the British people if if
if Israel was to come here and take over
the UK and have apartheid and have two
kind of laws for two different people
and raped this bastards the
scums family members killed his children
and imagine me as a TV anchor showing in
a video his family members and I go
these
monsters they are monsters now report
this dirt back to the offc come inah as
you can see brother sisters and Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will deal with him we
are going to see brother have no shadow
of a doubt Ramadan is around the corner
we will see these people being dragged
to the Hellfire by their faces we have
no doubt I have no shadow of a doubt
that day is going to come where we see
these scums like Allah says in we will
see if the disbelievers are being paid
back for what they used to do and
hostile ones like this if I can somebody
can inshah one day I hope I come across
this guy face to face I will absolutely
humiliate him and Report GB news tocom
guys and inshallah brothers and sisters
Hold Steady and firm
inshah this man who is a Zionist sh
who's being paid while his own people
while his own youngsters yes is being
destroyed by the zionists who own porob
who own these places Who are the
destroying the Next Generation while
they asleep and think Islam and the
Palestinians is a threet my friends
zionists are
systematically destroying your
generation and you are going to realize
that one day because the whole world is
waking up to the reality of the Zionist
they are behind every evil they are
behind every false flag call it a
conspiracy theory everyone is waking up
to the reality that's all I wanted to
say till next time
to and be sure that Allah subhah wa
ta'ala will deal with
them Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support every person who prays there
every kid that learns about Islam every
youngster that memorize the Quran all of
this and so much more can be on your
scale of Good Deeds click the link and
donate what you can and share the video
for even extra reward